[Music]
order
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic and this
is Niagara Falls I'm at one of the
largest waterfalls in the world and to
celebrate I'm gonna let you yes you the
people decide what I'm gonna do next
here at Niagara Falls so how about it
everyone you have me here at Niagara
Falls what would you like me to review
[Music]
hey really because I cuss when you're
gonna choose the Marilyn Monroe movie
Niagra the romance between her and
Joseph Cotten has been described as a
raging torrent of emotion that even
nature can't control but Murrow plays a
tantalizing temptress that kisses fired
Man Souls
you can't deny such poorly worded smut
alright fine I'll review this movie that
has nothing to do with Niagara Falls but
you guys have wanted me to review for
years
what about the script it doesn't matter
people made up their minds
I wanted to play new oh come on in this
desert great review you know Malcolm
would get the part head but what about
the guest stars we're just gonna have to
can them to shoot canceled
well I know a gaggle of hookers soon to
have my name on them it's locked from
the outside well that goes along with
him cutting the phone and the TV who
does that he said it'd keep us in
character as what Amish bed testers is
that why he also took our phones and
deep-fried them I really should John
laughing why are we doing things with
him for those who don't know years ago
I've reviewed an animated Titanic
musical known as Titanic the legend goes
up not only was it an obvious ripoff of
the James Cameron film but it had races
singing mice a forced happy ending and a
rapping dog yeah a rapping dog on the
Titanic it was one of the most tasteless
abominations ever at least it was until
I found another animated Titanic musical
called The Legend of Titanic it had
races singing mice a forced happy ending
but no rapping dog no no no no that was
replaced with a glove sniffing fetishes
sharks that escaped from jail that sink
the ship instead of an iceberg and a
giant puppy-dog squid who puts the ship
back together so that everyone can get
out alive good chocolate-coated God as
if having two of these in existence
wasn't enough for Skynet to want to kill
us but this last one actually got a
sequel because sinking the Titanic was
clearly just part one the sequels the
one we're looking at today called in
search of the Titanic
just when you thought things couldn't
possibly get any stupider in a world
that focuses on the sinking of the
Titanic what does this one throw in
atlantis yeah Titanic and Atlantis now
exist in the same universe 12 I guess it
is the next logical step it just keeps
going in descending order Titanic in
Atlantis Titanic in space Titanic
assignment Miami Beach and of course
Titanic in the hood this is leading the
funny thing is this wasn't even
originally coalbed it was originally
called tentacle inna the name of the
puppy puss in the last one even though
he's barely in it but his name was
changed from the Italian version to
something more simple what ever they
choose to call him a deep body auntie
yeah any of these and thus it became a
Titanic movie once again meaning I have
to review it then believe it or not it
is actually no joke
not kidding even worse than the other
two not one hint of sarcasm this is the
worst one now I do have this tradition
of drinking a rather large bottle of
Jager every time I view one of these and
seeing that this is somehow the absolute
worst out of all of them it's time to
push the button
I know where I'm vacationing this week
let us begin we start with a recap of
the last film and if you think you know
the story of the Titanic and don't need
a recap you clearly haven't seen it from
writers whose everyday dinner looks like
this it was called the ripoff of Dreams
and it was it really was
it says the film takes place three years
after the Titanic sunk where apparently
there's been quite the technology boom
in those short years I guess the 2001
aliens are dropping model is on marine
biologists but it looks like they only
got half the Enlightenment because the
only people going down to surf for the
Titanic are two of the passengers and
their dog from the first one um are they
really qualified just because they were
on the Titanic doesn't mean they can
find the damn thing hey I know where
Amelia Earhart is because I watched an
episode of Star Trek she was on millions
and research funds please I guarantee
you though there guess he stranger
things in this yellow submarine and the
Beatles ever did starting with their dog
who can talk to them that it seems to me
there are a lot of nasty looking sharks
out there oh it must be those magic
moonbeams in the last film that came
from a woman's tears that you know life
is too precious it's not worth the time
and don't forget about the little mice
friends from the last one we're just as
afraid of the Sharks watching them as
the dog is we're at sea this is their
home honestly there really isn't
anything to worry about
sharks indeed they're worse than cats
even cats eat mice ah we lose thousands
of lives to your house pets every day
it's funny it's funny
cut to immediate style change crisis
layer across swimming through here tense
we're shouting yo yo yo
teeth they're so sharp why didn't see
why do these movies near abs arms I just
don't see the connection was the rap
song in the other film such a worldwide
phenomenon that the movie said hey we
can make it wider there's a while please
allow me I'm a great big genius that
lives in your seat cuckoo man you better
look out there's gonna be a rap battle
between this and the Polar Express chefs
who seemed a hot chocolate song what the
hell are they even saying it's so gargle
that I think what you're supposed to
interpret our own lyrics so the head of
the Sharks is told about the Simpson
testicle and he tells his minions to
attack it why his detailed reasoning
will send shivers down your spine are
you sure it's yellow I hate that color I
can't stand yellow Macbeth had the inner
duality of acquiring power while holding
on to his humanity a had demonstrated
how revenge can destroy others as well
as yourself this character hates yellow
if that really the established
motivation doesn't give you goose bumps
I weep for you so he orders the Sharks
to start singing their teeth into it
what's happening
calm down smile relax it must have been
an underwater current he couldn't be
those things I say wouldn't attack us
attacking let's make another joke about
cats let's cut the cables they chew on
the cable so discreetly that they don't
make any sound effects
let's be on silent running as they're
tossed around inside try to stay calm
yeah because that worked so well before
what was your advice in the Titanic read
a book the cable is cut but the shirts
don't want to finish them off just yet
the reason right now I have to go and
brush my teeth a lot of people
underestimate the importance of shark
dental hygiene but in a bizarre twist
the Sharks are also in cahoots with the
bad guy from the first film as they
communicate via jellyfish telegram okay
Jeffrey now this is important
I want our mini submarines to be in a
permanent state of alert yes how many
summaries do they have back then if your
evil plans to get rich I'd say mission
already accomplished our muppet tentacle
porn comes across the sink and sub but
can't pull it out even though you was
originally strong enough to put the
Titanic back together who can he get to
help
oh it begins hey up an army of every 80s
girl toy that ever existed arrived and
tell the crap deploys that they can help
thank God they use their advanced
technology a bubble in a can and ride
their literal sea horses to the city of
Atlantis their dog smile wakes up to see
what's happening oh I'm dead Keep Calm
you're all safe no I'm dead and you're
taking me to doggy
L Wow thanks for putting that idea into
kids heads did your puppy ever bite you
he could go here they'd take them to dr.
Calamity Jane as our heroes discover
that Atlantis is kind of like a creepy
comfort in except somehow even more
hostile go and get things ready
immediately get what ready calm down me
yes to be able to Wow
what an asshole talk out of line again
and I will smite down upon thee with
great vengeance and furious anger you
will know my name is the Lord you have
to drink the elixir before you visit the
city of course Keep Calm if they want to
thank you have you noticed all the
bullshit of God you men well charge Keep
Calm we're gonna drown Keep Calm take
this incredibly suspicious shit this
elixir is such a pretty color
when crossbows are especially adorable
[Music]
I'm honored to introduce to you my
squadron of mermaids and mermen by why'd
we show up for this again does he think
we can hear him through that we must go
it's getting late
the mall closes half-past kidnap o'clock
how do you like it no dreams make sense
compared to this they then take him to a
room full of toys who have the ability
to speak and achieve conscious thought
how is this possible everything lives
moves and things even if it seems
impossible at times oh that explains
that how about a creepy song number here
is a surprise oh you can thank your
lucky stars that I have saved your lives
I don't like this guy's voice it sounds
like the Cryptkeeper if he was choking
on Gollum I will save me that mistake
Atlantis easy pony babe will you always
stay away this is the last thing we'll
see before we die but you know what this
song really needs brave music no Moloch
is fresh you can sleep around this yo
take it's a deal you'll soon come into
my shelf a dozen
every single day it's all about this
review was writing itself I'm not
getting this review with literally
writing itself this is so terrifyingly
batshit insane that you can actually
hear someone off-screen declare this is
scary I'm not even kidding
listen closely do you hear that I swear
she said this is scary
yes it is pourcel I think we know who
the real survivors involving the Titanic
should be but the musical counselor
let's some uncomfortable news slip you
can't go oh I'm sorry I was supposed to
tell you that after the chloroform
sprinklers went off
holy Christ I need a drink hey go check
my Jaeger planet
we can go high
there's a sir
you
today end up meeting the king of
Atlantis and Wow
from now on Atlantis will be your home
and you will not be able to lead it
who's a ring Wraith now I hope you will
accept my apologies for the lack of tact
displayed by our counselor when he gave
you the news on the contrary it's better
that we were told about the situation
right away and I have to say your
counsellor informed us in the most
amusing way which helped us all to see
the benefits yes I love being told I'm a
hostage via bullsh in music that even
Radio Disney would throw an acid clearly
you thought long and hard about this
he's also told that the elixir not only
has them breathe underwater but also can
have them live forever
again would have been a nice nugget of
knowledge to know earlier your friends
aren't still getting over the shock of
the news are they
no they're still a bit surprised by it
but they understand that we had no
choice in the matter
what are you smoking to be so okay with
this now it might be a really good time
for you to get angry our mice friends
come across other mice in Atlantis
because that's a comment Atlantean
infestation and it turns out there are
even more offensive stereotypes than
that hey yo can ever be too prudent
after y'all everything is ready
there's all fun but you'll can trust us
your dog get out of here go and take the
flash with your ah we call him Mickey
Mouse Rooney well that's going on smile
comes across a new companion
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa slow down
we have even sniffed each other's asses
yet no yeah I guess that scene was over
this movie has the smooth transition of
a slap to your balls who are these the
chief did say that all the rats should
be present you idiot
you're so stupid I bet you'd appear in
the same background at a jump cut so the
rats of this underwater world don't like
the Atlanteans and want to take them
over let's take a huge stash of the
elixir of life with us the elixir we'll
be able to conquer the world and will
offer that annoying little pink octopus
as a present to razor teeth that fish is
the one that causes all the property
yes she's our alum Wow I never
accumulated so many questions in such a
short amount of time how did the rats
get there if they didn't drink the
elixir
how can they be there how will the
elixir make them rule the world why do
they want to rule the world what issues
do they have with the Atlantean
government how does the Atlantean
government work what do they think the
octopus causes all the problems how are
they in contact with the Sharks why are
they in contact with the Sharks this
bullshit makes a little sense you could
call it Brent Atlantis this news
eventually gets back to our heroes this
time we should all be there do I make
myself perfectly clear smile but I can't
come I'm really scared of water I had a
bad experience when I was only a puppy
oh and being on the Titanic probably
played a small part in that oh yeah by
the way aren't we supposed to be looking
for that for a film called in search of
Titanic there's very little searching
for the Titanic even for the original
title tentacle II know he's barely in
this either you might as well call it
lets you one lady foot and make about as
much sense it'd be far more engaging so
they tell the King about the evil plot
and how they also plan to take apart his
counselor if they dismantle me with a
screwdriver I'll die they'll have to
have a screwdriver and down here
lantus there are no screwdrivers they've
all been banned well wait a minute no
screwdrivers um all of this city was
made with no screwdrivers boy dealers in
this city must be very interesting so
they agreed to let them do the
revolution I mean they are just friggin
rats and to stop them in the middle of
it we'll replace the flask of elixir
with a false one which will be full of
water I'm ready to serve your majesty
we must prepare for battle all we have
to do is win
you've made everyone Dumber for saying
that so they help them get the fake
elixir but the Atlanteans are there to
head them off
I'm sending you all to doggie hell you
hear me
doggie howl which we just go ahead and
test attack wow look at all those ships
and that one screwdriver was used on any
of them Tello spittin blood goes a long
way so all the toys are marching into
battle when somebody spots a little girl
doll in the army
a little girl little one I appreciate
your effort but this is no place for
someone like you what is your name my
child for the love of broken fact pipe
ah it's not a little girl I'm the
commander of the mountain artillery
troops it's a curse not a disguise I'm
fouled up like this because I fell into
the hands of a little girl who thought
she'd put a wig on me when she saw me
with this skirt on Your Majesty don't
come near me let me fight I have to
banish this curse that's haunting me and
regain my identity
okay um some notes how is the little
girl dressing you up a curse it's just a
little girl dressing you up there's no
supernatural elements the second why
don't you just take the wig off along
with the makeup
in fact you're underwater how's a stay
on anyway
does that mean the curse is gone now
whatever weird curse you think your
Parker Brother Ouija board gave you from
now on you have a new leader a new
general the general brew Molly and I'm
not even kidding this character never
comes back the strange backstory the
curse the nonsensical story arc none of
it plays a part in anything it was 100%
pointless well thank you for that when
ever somebody brings up a Scottish toy
who fought in a war who was cursed to
look like a little girl but fired a
cannon lifting the curse and promoting
him to general
Kai still won't reference you so he's at
the bad guys ship with some sort of
forgetting ray okay and the bad guy
totally forgets his plans or if he ever
had any at all yeah what was his chemos
Jeffrey tell me what was happening
because the rats also find out that the
elixir they got isn't the real elixir as
they tested on this old man whom they
tied to Briggs and try to drown you know
and started to think these were the rats
nymph watch down the toilet tricks them
so that they'll never hurt anyone again
ah was that one with a breath why was
there a random shot of pink through
there was it a subliminal message
letting us know the film is always
watching us starboard we've won with a
battery and as a reward to our heroes
they clean up and put together the
Titanic yeah remember that the title of
the goddamn movie we finished your
excellency complete with dead bodies and
everything driver God
in fact the screwdriver can talk to ya I
can think it can make choices I can do
anything just like all the other things
that that makes it kind of worse same I
want an entire group of people just for
existing that's America's job so they
take the ship and our heroes to the Isle
of naboombu where they say they'll live
the rest of their immortal lives um
sweet this is a secret island
unreachable by anyone and here you will
live happily ever after thanks again for
kidnapping us forcing us to live forever
happiness fighting your wars and
dropping us off on deserted island
ah thank God we have no friends back
home and that was the search for Titanic
by far the worst of the movies not
because of how historically insensitive
it is you could claim the others are
worse for that but just for what a
poorly made nonsensical totally mad
collection of ravings it is the imagery
in this film is beyond bonkers and the
reasons for the imagery are the
invitation to a dark hallway of insanity
I wouldn't wish upon my worst enemy it
is beyond words it is a sickness it is
the worst in the animated musical
Titanic trilogy and I am so sad we live
in a world where that's a thing holy
goddamn hell
where this movie is an infection now let
me tell you it's infected me it's gonna
take a long time to get rid of it
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic and I
Will Survive you know it's funny in the
end all I had to do was think of people
less fortunate than me that somehow just
cleared everything up just thinking of
people less fortunate than me
it's not that I'm ashamed of the name
cricket li I just I thought it'd be a
show about a cartoon insects who studies
come food now it's never gonna happen
don't say that yeah well make it happen
actually I think there is a porno of it
[Music]
you guys have a good rest that's
fantastic what are you still doing here
get out there and see the sights if you
could sign these forms just saying that
you want sue me for any felonies I may
or may not have committed that'd be
phenomenal so yeah go out there see
Niagara Niagara guys it's so great then
get out that you put your knuckleheads
[Music]
you
all we have to do is win
coming next week does PG mean anything
anymore come on guys you need parental
guidance for this but you can see it now
under vessels ad free early exits just
three dollars a month to see tons of
people's videos early as well as a bunch
of other extra features check it out and
get the early scoop hey Doug Walker here
doing the charity shout out this week we
are doing the American Foundation for
children with AIDS this is a nonprofit
organization providing critical support
to infected and affected hiv-positive
children and their caregivers since 2005
in collaboration with their in-country
partners they've served tens of
thousands of families and marginalized
communities in Africa the areas of
impact include medical support
livelihoods nutrition educational
support and emergency relief
currently the AFCA is transforming lives
in Kenya Uganda Zimbabwe and the
Democratic Republic of Congo if you look
at their website and their YouTube
channel you can see all the young lives
you can make better by simply donating
even the smallest amount as their motto
goes hope is a spark that changes lives
and the AFCA provides hope to thousands
of children in Africa check them out and
see how you can keep the spark still
glowing
[Music]